Mark here CEO and founder of tungle
today I'm really excited we are now
supporting notes we've been working with
the folks from IBM for the past year to
get this to you uh so now we're
supporting 99% of all business calendars
used by professionals all around the
world so that includes Outlook with or
without exchange Google Calendar Mac IAL
and Entourage and now notes we're doing
a a uh controlled roll out so you can go
to lotus. tungle do me to actually sign
up to be part of this limited beta let
me show you how it
works this here is my notes
environment uh tongle first thing that
we do is we keep in sync both your
contact list and your calendar with
tongo so if I go to tongle right now
which by the way notes allows you to see
it within in the environment of notes so
you don't need to open up a new browser
and so on you can see that my calendar
and contact list it is perfectly in sync
with my notes calendar and contact but
what's the beauty of having tungle
within your environment is that you can
also share calendars with people inside
and outside your office no matter which
calendar application they're using so
for example jacu here is sharing the
detail of his calendar with me and he
could have been sharing only his free
busy uh but he's on Google Calendar and
the other person could have on Outlook
and so on and so forth now what about
scheduling that important meeting which
is what tungle really does so I get here
an email from Jason and Jason uh
basically says hey I'd love to see a
demo of this thing so instead of opening
up a browser and trying to type the
names and so on the only thing I need to
do is go to this little toolbar here and
click on schedule so what it does it
opens a tungle window and pre populates
it with the subject and the people that
were included in the email and so now
all I really need to do is go to the
calendar and start proposing times for
the meeting it's pretty cool so now uh I
can get a meeting link or uh send it now
and then the meeting gets booked so
that's about it so give it a try let us
know how it goes uh we're always hungry
for your feedback um so again uh we're
really excited if you're at lotusphere
come and see us uh we're walking around
you can always tungle me at tungle me/
markmc have a good
day